la frontière,
Raphaël Bouvier Auclair.
- Après des heures d'anxiété,
le soulagement de revoir des
proches maintenant en sécurité.
C'est au compte goute
que dizaines de milliers
d'Ukrainiens traversent
la frontière après un long
et difficile voyage pour
fuir la guerre.
- Un trajet en voiture, un autre
en autobus et enfin huit heures
de marche. Voilà le parcours
- Un trajet en voi a a a a autre
en autobus et enfin huit heures
de marche. Voilà le parcours
de ces femmes qui viennent
d'une ville pourtant située
à seulement 80 kilomètres
de la Pologn
On se trouve à quelques
centaines de mètres à peine
de l'Ukraine et, vous voyez,
les gens ne cessent d'entrer en
Pologne en attendant parfois de
loururururures, de très longues
heures. Une famille nous a dit
même avoir attendu 20 heures
avant de pouvoir rentrer dans ce
pays de l'Union européenne pour
y trouver refuge et une fois que
les réfugiés ukrainiens arrivent
en Pologne, les besoins sont
très grands.
Que ce soit en voiture ou
à pied, les scénarios sont
semblables à tous les points
d'entrée. Tous les modes
de transport sont bons pour
d d d d d du conflit armé.
Cette gare, à une quinzaine
de kilomètres de la frontière,
accueille les rares trains
qui quittent encore l'Ukraine.
Une station devenue un centre
d'accueil pour accompagner
des centaines de réfugiés.
e e e e e e e d'aider sa mère
qui a de la difficulté à quitter
le pays, mais elle ne sait pas
quand elle poura y arriver.
En plus de l'attente de parfois
24 heures aux postes
frontaliers, les déplacements
sont compliqués. Ces congolais
installés en Ukraine l'ont bien
constaté s s s s s s sont prises
d'assaut. Pour atteindre
la frontière, la marche
s'est finalement imposée. m m me
20 kilomètres à pieds parce
qu'il n'y avait pas de
transport. Les Ukrainiens
étaient là-bas, leurs chauffeurs
disaient : "Bon, on s'arrête
ici. Là-bas il y a
l'embouteillage, il y a pas
moyen de continuer."
t t t t t t t t rendu en Ukraine
il y a deux ans à la recherche
d'une vie meilleure. Il doit
maintenant fuir un conflit
MEHDI, réfugié
- Nous avons vu des histoires
qu'on n'a jamais vues.
Des gens mourir comme ça n n n s
images... je ne sais pas si
je les oublierai dans ma vie.
- Ils sont nombreux ici, à ne
pas savoir ce qui les attend.
Combien de temps resteront-ils?
Pourront-ils trouver
un logement? Afin de les aider,
les autorités polonaises etune t
mobilisés. Pour Mira, l'idée
d'aider à distribuer de
la nourriture s'est rapidement
imposée. Cette polonai
d'origine ukrainienne dit avoir
de la difficulté à s'exprimer.
- "Des gens viennent
littéralement de l'enf
dit-elle. Tania ne pouvait
pas s'imaginer que la Russie
puisse attaquer son pays
de cette manière.
- Colère, solidarité,
peur et incompréhension.
À la frontière entre la Pologne
et l'Ukraine, se croisent
des momomomomomomomomomotions.
Ici Raphaël Bouvier Auclair,
Radio-Canada à Medyk